[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me tom
heap coming up in the next half hour
[Music]
coming up in the next half hour we'll be
looking at this extraordinary week in uk
weather and what are the consequences
for the future of our country we'll also
be looking at the impact
of the on the tory party leadership race
and
also internationally how this is
affecting the weather and the response
to it across the world
[Music]
hello welcome to the daily climate show
a record-shattering week in
in record-shattering week of weather
that didn't just
pass the climate change uh the the
man-made climate change figure there is
no doubt that man-made climate change
made things hotter
these are live pictures from wellington
that was the village that was really
really much of it destroyed by the fire
you can see many of the burnt out
buildings still there and the fields as
well beside them where the fire swept
across
let's work out what happened there
here's adam parker
it was the busiest day for the london
fire brigade since world war ii
we tracked the path of the fire in
wennington in east london the fire
starts at around 1 pm the temperature is
37 degrees and it will rise for the next
few hours
this video shows resident alfie stock
trying to put out the early stages of
the fire with a garden hose he lives
here at 22 the green he says the fire
started in a compost pile at the house
next door that was empty at the time
the exact cause of the fire is still
being investigated the london fire
brigade received the first call alerting
them to the incident at 106 pm they
arrive seven minutes later the fire
started less than a hundred meters from
wellington fire station the crews base
there were five miles away in upminster
attending another fire
the sky news helicopter is heading to
the essex coastline and spots the fire
alfie stock's house here at number 22
and next door are already gutted and the
fire has spread to number 20.
the wind direction appears to be playing
a big part in how the fire spreads
further it's moving north west pushing
the fire towards more houses
it's been an hour since the fire started
and it's travelled more than 200 metres
west to these gardens ten minutes later
at 2 28 it's reached this house and
completely engulfed the large
outbuilding
in the fields to the south landowners
are trying to stop the spread by
creating a channel in the field using a
tractor and are moving water containers
in to help
but it doesn't work two hours later we
can see the landowners fail to stop the
spread and it's continued to move south
across the fields
and in the village the fire has now
moved 400 metres west
five houses on wellington road in our
lights and it's moving fast nine minutes
later a further two houses have caught
fire
[Music]
in video film the next morning the
grounds of the church are charred but
the building itself remains intact
in total we counted 16 houses severely
damaged plus a number of other buildings
including garages and stables
it took the fire brigade eight hours to
get it under control
that was adam parker from sky's data and
forensics team there i'm very sorry
about that somewhat shaky introduction
to the program we had a little problem
with uh autocue uh correspondent sadia
chowdhury is in wellington
well it's been about two days since this
fire ripped through wellington village
and still today
large parts of it are behind the cordon
as fire workers continue their
investigations into what happened here
but for the residents the impact is
incredible there are some people who
don't know whether their properties have
been burnt they say that they haven't
been given enough updates they don't
know when they'll be able to go back to
their residences some people that we've
spoken to held back tears as they said
that they expect to be so for surfing
for the next couple of weeks
as they look at repairing their homes or
potentially needing to find new homes
and many of them very frustrated by the
length of time that it's taking to carry
out these investigations
the london fire brigade haven't given
any indication on how long this
investigation might take but they have
said that their workers are trying to
make sure that the area is safe that
they need to assess the extent of the
damage and crucially to find out what
the cause of the fire was
well let's look at these the highest
temperatures ever in three of the four
nations of the uk
the 40.3 degree mark degree marker
didn't just break the uk record but it
obliterated it in the words of one
climate scientist it's so far from the
norm if a record was broken by this much
in sport well foul play would be
suspected
and this is the guilty party man-made
climate change here is the graph of
average global temperature rises since
1880 when the industrial revolution
took off
when it's hotter on average the spikes
are likely to be higher too
well the flames reached wellington
because they spread across fields and
across britain hundreds of acres have
gone up in flames this is a threat to
food supplies farming comes and wildlife
well let's talk to a farmer who has felt
this firsthand
tom martin runs a family farm near
peterborough and cambridgeshire and his
whole fields were nearly caught up in
tuesday's fires tom you were there
yourself what actually happened
well that's right we could see our
neighbour's farm from our farm and we
could see whether um uh that the
telegraph wire had uh had struck against
a tree uh which of course the wire had
sagged in the in the heat uh it had
struck the ground uh and uh set light to
to the hedgerow and about 100 yards of
the hedgerow were burning and
threatening the crops in the field next
door
and really what was at stake here if if
this had taken off and the fire actually
got beyond the hedge
well this was at two o'clock on tuesday
afternoon when the temperature was 38
degrees celsius and the winds were 20
miles an hour and there are all around
me hundreds of acres of standing grain
uh worth about two and a half thousand
pounds per hectare uh so there's a huge
amount of value but of course it's not
just that it's a potential loss a threat
of life as well
you've farmed in that area for quite a
while and presumably some of your fields
border villages as well are you thinking
this threat of fire might well change
the way you sort of plant and grow crops
yeah we've always been uh very wary
about fire um but this things are really
changing now it is is extreme to levels
that we've not experienced before um we
probably won't be changing the the types
of crops but we'll be looking at more
drought resistant varieties and we'll be
trying to improve our soil health so
that it retains the moisture better and
allows our plants to stay greener longer
well i wanted to talk to you about
drought because that's perhaps the
somewhat forgotten story of this year
because it doesn't come in a in a
massive peak like we saw with the heat
but just how dry is it in in your part
of eastern england
it's incredibly dry our rainfall is down
about 40 we haven't had meaningful rain
here for probably two to three months
and the ground around me is cracked uh
the clay soils have really shrunk up uh
and and it's desperately desperately dry
it's a tinderbox
yeah and what do you think that will
mean in terms of your future in terms of
maybe the varieties of crop you grow or
anything are there things you can plant
that would be more drought tolerant
well as we make decisions as farmers
really from now forward uh all our
decisions will have to be referencing
the climate we've seen more extremes of
hot and cold of of wet and dry and so
we're gonna have to be thinking uh in
all our decisions about about climate uh
and the extremes that we've seen
well thanks very much indeed tom i hope
some of those great clouds behind your
head might actually bear some rain for
you but i have my doubts thanks very
much indeed
well alongside the destructive heat wave
the other big story this week has been
the contest to be the next leader of the
conservative party and prime minister
well it's fair to say that none of the
candidates have really been championing
their own green credentials yesterday
president of cop 26 that's last year's
big climate summit in glasgow alok
sharma called on the next prime minister
to make the net zero target a key focus
what i would certainly want to see from
any future prime minister is a
laser-like focus on ensuring that we are
delivering on our policies on net zero
missions but at the same time
pushing forward on more jobs more growth
more inward investment which we have
seen coming in the last few days uh i
have been a real wake-up call for
everyone in this country it's what very
very many millions of people across the
world are experiencing on a regular
basis we have to deal with this issue
so let's have a look at the two
remaining contenders
rishi sunak has committed to reaching
net zero emissions by
2050 and he was part of the government
that was committed to this target too
but he has expressed some caution saying
the move to net zero should not be too
hard and fast and we should prioritize
jobs as chancellor he cut fuel duty and
tax on short-haul domestic flights but
also introduced a 5 billion pound tax on
oil and gas companies
he's pledged to limit building any new
onshore wind farms and wants the focus
to be offshore instead
this would be part of a policy to make
the uk energy self-sufficient by 2045.
liz truss has also committed to net zero
but in a similar way to sunac she said
we need to find better ways to deliver
it that won't harm people and businesses
and just this morning she pledged a
moratorium that's in effect a suspension
on so-called green levees to help cut
people's energy bills
as environment secretary under david
cameron she's scrapped subsidies for the
development of new solar panels calling
them ugly and a blight on the
countryside and as foreign secretary she
has rarely mentioned climate change or
environmental issues with the uk's
international partners well
uh correspondent mari aurora joins us
now from westminster uh mari is it fair
to say that neither candidate has really
been playing on their green credentials
yes i think it would be
fair to say that the issue at the moment
with this tory leadership race is that
the priority is the economy and the
economy is completely and utterly
dominating the political conversation
here in westminster
so as you said trust lizzie trust that
she has uh pledged to have a complete
moratorium on green levees she's very
much seen as a kind of right-wing
candidate that she's rallying the right
wing of the tory party together and the
right side of the tory party aren't very
convinced by the net zero agenda and by
the green agenda alex sharma as you say
the cop 26 president he said
specifically on scrapping green levees
that it wasn't green levees that was
going to change people's household bills
massively the issue really when it comes
to bills with green levees was to do
with the wholesale wholesale price of
gas across the world so both candidates
very kind of
careful about how they approach the
environmental question in their policy
agenda because they're addressing
anxieties amongst touring members tory
voters and tory mps when it comes to
jobs and livelihoods and those being
threatened by a pushing green agenda
essentially
well thanks very much indeed uh for that
mari and we'll hear more from our uh
correspondents across europe as intense
wildfires scorched france and spain
could there be lessons there for the uk
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
they have reached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisively
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
the
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show on sky
news in the week when global warming got
personal and for some people actually
burnt down the house but this is a
global problem
let's have a look at this figure we have
always ticking away here on our data
dashboard the long one there this is the
average amount in degrees that the world
has warmed up since pre-industrial times
and you can see it's running at 1.25 and
quite a few decimal points but in many
continents the increase is much larger
let's start with europe the average
annual temperature over the european
land areas in the last decade was close
to two degrees warmer than the than in
the pre-industrial period
the heat wave here has triggered
wildfires and cost lives and seen homes
evacuated today temperatures in europe
mostly remain in the high 30s
the land has been ablaze across many
square miles of france spain italy
portugal and greece
in france the fires ravaged the south
western girond region and it's from
there where siobhan robbins reports
[Music]
they're france's worst wildfires in 30
years
for more than a week crews have been
trying to get two massive blazes in the
southwest under control disaster
inflamed by so-called apocalyptic heat
due to climate change
these are some of more than 37 000
people driven from their homes by the
flames
louisette and mark grabbed the dog and
fled but the cat was missing
unespecially
the damage caused by the fires is
staggering
whole campsites reduce to ruins
once green forests now blackened and
broken
the burned land already has a bigger
surface area than paris
for the fire crews who've been battling
day and night it's depressing
as well as fighting the fire from the
air
and ground they're also doing this
clearing land the width of the m25 in an
attempt to contain the flames
it may seem counterintuitive to cut down
trees to save a forest but this is all
about
denying the fire fuel and they're
clearing these huge areas in the hope of
stopping sparks from jumping
so much has already been lost and this
isn't over
the french president has pledged to
replant forests but the shock waves from
this disaster will be felt long after
the final flames have been put out
siobhan robbins sky news gerard
southwest france
well from siobhan robbins in france we
go to our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter who's in zamora in
northwestern spain uh hannah start by
telling me really what's been going on
around you there
i've spent the last couple of weeks
travelled to portugal and to spain both
countries with whole regions in the grip
of a natural disaster there's no other
way to describe it wildfires fires
causing particular suffering ripping
through these communities destroying
tens of thousands of acres burning homes
and businesses down
ending livelihoods injuring people there
have been a number of deaths and
hundreds of heat related deaths actually
and for some of these communities
particularly those small lower income
communities in the mountains of spain
where i am at the moment there will be
no way back the
villages some of them are just gone we
were filming in one just a few uh hours
ago and as we were there a house
collapsed beside us they're very
dangerous and it's hard for those
communities to know
when to come back so of course there's
this emergency response but of course
these nations are looking forward now
knowing that climate change is going to
make fire season worse and heat worse
and they're really starting to think
about how they can live with this new
reality well do they have any ideas
about how that might happen and could
there be lessons for us here in the uk
well these countries are obviously hot
but now they're getting hotter they
understand how to arrange their day to
avoid the hottest part of the day in the
summer months but there are recent
adaptations for example in seville
they've appointed a chief heat officer
and they've started naming heat waves as
if you might name a hurricane so people
can get to the grips with the idea that
these things are life-threatening events
and then you've perhaps got the most
extreme adaptation of all and in both
portugal and in spain people told me
that they were genuinely thinking about
whether or not they could stay put in
their communities if the threat from
climate change keeps growing
wow sort of depopulation of the country
so quite extraordinary hannah thomas
peter thank you very much indeed
in america 100 million u.s citizens are
under heat warnings this week with
little let up in sight and yesterday
president biden vowed to combat the
climate crisis
climate change is literally an
existential threat to our nation and to
the world so my message today is this
since congress is not acting as it
should and these guys here are but we're
not getting many republican votes this
is an emergency an emergency and i will
i will look at it that way i said last
week uh say it again loud and clear as
president i'll use my executive powers
to combat climate the climate crisis and
the absence of congressional action
well joining me from the u.s is rachel
kite an expert in climate change and
policy from tufts university in
massachusetts and a member of the un
secretary general's climate advisory
group rachel very very good to see you
the big question for me here is when you
combine this extraordinary weather
across much of the northern hemisphere
with the pressure on fuel price rises
are we finally seeing a bit of a policy
change towards perhaps more
climate-friendly ideas
well we need to um but i think that in
the very good session you've just
shown with the
your commentators and the filming we're
still and too many political leaders are
sort of thinking about the economy on
the one side and then climate and its
impacts on the other
in fact the answers lie in economic
policy the future of our ability to
combat climate change and live with it
depends on how we integrate our it into
our economic planning so
in the uk um
we we have to uh change the way that we
generate energy we're going to have to
invest a lot in communities to make them
more resilient
and if we don't we're going to be in
trouble it's also
a case that 80 of the world now has a
net zero target so it's really about
implementing change uh not seeing that
climate change is something divorced
from the economy the future of the
economy and its competitiveness depends
on the way in which we will combat
climate change rachel sort of below if
you like high level politics what are we
seeing in terms of
investment decisions and actual build
out of renewable energy resources for
instance what's the trend there
well i think that the trend is that
renewable energy has been uh growing
exponentially uh around the world it
started to slow down a little bit during
the sort of pandemic years but now we
need to pick it up again and of course
we now are pivoting away from russian
hydrocarbons in europe etcetera so we
need to continue this exponential growth
of installation of renewable energy but
we need to do it everywhere and i think
the the point is that we're just not
going fast enough and so it really does
matter that we incentivize renewable
energy installation and that's where u.s
congress is having problems and it's
where candidates for the uk premiership
are also having problems
so we do need to expand it and then we
need to invest in how to make
communities cope with climate change
better
and just from your u.s experience um
just briefly if you can what kind of
pressures is biden under uh in the sort
of the federal level but also what's
happening on the state level if you
could compress those two for me
well at the state level um mayors and
cities are doing what they can and here
in boston
the mayor mayor wu has a 26 point
resilience plan to help the city become
a cooler city because we're going to get
the kinds of heat waves we've got this
week on a continued basis
the problem is at the federal level
politics has meant that climate change
has become a pawn and while there is not
so much climate denial there is a lot of
climate delay and that delay is as
dangerous as denial when we've got this
kind of weather rachel kite i'm terribly
sorry we will have to leave it there but
thank you very much indeed for your time
well that is all from us today i'll be
back at the weekend with a special
program on aviation asking if we have a
hope of keeping our flight connected
world without cooking the planet well
chuck's away and back to you sarah jane
tom thank you i just want to update
viewers on the breaking news we brought
you just before the climate show the
special edition that is president biden
has tested positive for covid we've just
heard from the president's doctor who
said that president biden felt tired had
a runny nose and a dry cough
typical symptoms of kovid he said that
potus went to bed and felt fine but
didn't sleep well and tested positive
this morning a spokesperson for boris
johnson has said that
boris johnson has sent president biden
his best wishes and hopes he has a
speedy recovery from covert more after
the break
[Music]
you